ich gehe auf den server nehme mir die
sachen aus der kiste baue den weg und
dann einfach nur laufen ich nicht die
ganzen teile mein puls ist oft 370 carlo
freuen und herzlich willkommen tsum
minecraft war teil vier befinden uns
hier gerade im menü hallodri machte am
besten mal deine uhr unten rechts noch
ein bisschen auf jetzt beginnt nämlich
die große jagd und wir versuchen jetzt
ich gucke schon hat man schon sein kann
man kann man kann schon sehen war kann
schon bald hin komme auf den server
schnell schächter
hallo ihr wissen drauf wir haben
eventuell einen kleinen vorteil ich
wusste noch gar nicht dass man schon
sein kann irgendwie ist die urform
server eventuell anders gestellt
ich nehme es die wichtigsten sachen ok
ich hab' das ich habe noch nicht das
wichtigste ich muss noch ein bisschen
was zu essen nehmen
okay wir überhaupt noch etwas schneller
schnellere messen aber kein essen
richtig gebraten und rockig mal dass
gartenweg ich karten weg ok hautnahes
drauf auch scheiße inderthal muss aber
zurück ein paar sachen mitnehmen alter
warum hier so dunkel ok kom kom kom kom
kom
ach so ja okay ich komme zurück alle
kommen darauf alle kommen darauf freunde
alle kommen gerade was ich habe ein paar
sachen okay okay ich baue jetzt hier in
den ofen den markt dann jedes teams dann
hinter uns okay verloren sich henkel
muss die jetzige situation also in part
2 wurde ein strike begangen aber nicht
nur von mir sondern auch von paletten
und von delay
deswegen sind die koordinaten von mir
paletten und die live veröffentlicht
worden ich habe vorhin noch mit den
beiden gesprochen mit halle und die
ganze zeit und die werden jetzt hat auch
save geträumt dann das heißt ich weiß
nicht ob ich jetzt drücken kann mal
lieber nicht am start im chat gesehen
richtig viele leute sind uns gerade
hinterher geschaut
die sich einfach nur denken ja wir
müssen unbedingt zu den hin die sind auf
dem server wir müssen irgendwie töten
weil unsere koordinaten öffentlich sind
das heißt unsere taktik ist jetzt
einfach laufen laufen laufen setzt du
hinter und schon blöcke
das gesetz zwei starken rückgang ist auf
jeden fall zu
okay aber nimmt am besten den ofen mal
wieder ab und setzen jetzt hinten hin
einfach direkt vor die bereiche
neurologie okay wir müssen immer so
viele steine wie möglich hinter uns
lassen ist willig steine rausnehmen und
so ist wie ich nicht will ja dass das
ist jetzt erst mal egal wir sind ja noch
relativ weit unten nur dass wir jetzt
jetzt erstmal so viele steine wie
möglich mache ich nämlich den weg geben
fällig oder besser gesagt bist du
irgendwelche namen siehst oder so ich
nehme jetzt sogar noch kohle mit hier
ebenso ein bisschen ich halte denke aber
ehrlich also wir wissen ja die
koordinaten und die koordinaten ich hab
mir die extra angeschaut von paletten
und delay sind relativ nahe beieinander
also ich weiß dass die beiden war ich
dachte gar nicht wieder zweite tags
effekt drin aber ich habe zum glück noch
faithfull dritte alter richtig eng alter
die koordinaten von den angeschaut und
die sind relativ nah beieinander
deswegen denke ich dass die auf die
beiden draufgehen vor allem die leicht
nur noch alleine im team und wir beide
zu zweit halt unter der erde
ich denke dass für uns niemand kommen
wird aber sicher ist sicher ich bin
schon relativ weit oben
ich schaue ich bin auf höhe 54 schon das
heißt fast schon wieder am ober grund
aber ich sehe auch keine namen bisher
noch nicht ich sehe keine namen okay
weil ich würde jetzt sagen dass ich
irgendwo anders hingehen einfach
weglaufen erstmal beziehungsweise ein
bisschen sneaker und unter der erde
bleiben
okay okay ich wollte mich jetzt soweit
hochbaum bist du für 60 bin das ist ja
etwa der minecraft level zumindest noch
nicht dass weder erde haben und dann
okay das erde darf er damit jetzt ungern
hin und jetzt nämlich einfach in eine
andere richtung
jetzt einfach ein bisschen eine andere
richtung gehen damit auch wenn die den
weg entdecken weiter denken dass wir
weiter hoch gegangen sind kaum ein hoch
über der höhle omar sagte würde
das war ein ganz ganz dumme idee gerade
schätze ich bin hier und ich mache jede
menge stein erweisen
ich mache jede menge steine untergang zu
zu bauen und garten nahm ich das bin ich
das kann sein das habe ich nicht genau
gelesen ich nicke jetzt wieder fleißig
ball bin besseren zweiten ofen gebastelt
damit wir doppelt soviel stand alone
okay ich mache jetzt am besten sogar die
wege so ein bisschen anders das heißt so
ein bisschen oder oder oder zeigt dass
wir das nachher alles volk leisten
können quasi dass uns niemand
nachverfolgen kann
das komische ist ich hätte halt echt
gedacht dass wenige oder steak oder
sonst in der härteren aber es ist ja
wirklich nur hautnah gekommen ich habe
unter gar nicht glauben
es sind echt wenig joint muss ich
wirklich sagen in der tat
der gang ist auf jeden fall jetzt
irgendwie mit sechs blöcken
hintereinander zu auf jeden fall
das sollte eigentlich sein auch wenn sie
jetzt zu unseren koordinaten kommen
hast du noch ende seid oder irgendwie so
was man da sieht habe ich damit am
besten da hinten noch hin
ich glaub ich glaube es kommt wirklich
keiner ich hatte richtig große angst
davor aber ich denke dass wird laufen
kann vielleicht hören dass ich ein
bisschen angeknackst bin von der stimme
her weil ich war auf einem festival
gästen bei einer fetten ich kann wieder
runter eben weil so langsam müssen wir
dann jetzt auch hoch weil der weg ist ja
dann auch egal wenn wir erst mal oben
sind
schau mal wegen beinstellen
ich halte mich noch irgendwie ein
bisschen ganz meine stein spitzhacke
machen eben oder was ich mache mir
selber ein ich glaube ich habe die
ganzen habe ich nicht muss man eine
machen
hochstein bin nämlich der profi und
werft die sachen zu ok ich denke sind
definitiv safe dass eigentlich niemand
mehr kommen weil ich schlecht
in welcher höhe war mir dann hier unten
440 ich kann mich einfach hier die
seiten rein vielleicht irgendwie noch
reisen oder oder war
findet man so komisch höheren erde unten
denn in höhlen findet hallodri leben
noch so starken resultat glücklich dass
ich keiner nach zurück wer hat lust auf
12 aus avignon passiert der will alleine
nein wenn man gar keine sachen ich hab
noch nicht mal wusste ich habe auch eine
rüstung style und halt mein schwert kann
es mir schon meine neue spitzhacke
machen eben aber ich mach dir natürlich
eine neue kreditlinie von dem mann
dahinten sind überall
ich finde gar kein eisen oder sowas ich
habe vorhin klein bisschen was gefunden
aber wahrscheinlich sind wir auch
einfach auf seiner richtigen scheiß höhe
dürfte die mal dahin fade und gespielt
und was verstehst du heilige scheiße
jetzt wird's spannend jetzt müssen wir
erstmal weg
okay ich bin auf jeden fall nicht hastig
auf die uhr geguckt ja wir sind bei acht
minuten
jetzt nimmt die sachen wenig es auch
hier alter scheiße war okay mir waren
jetzt nimm deine sachen war alles raus v
die öfen ab grafing table abnahm
aber warum sollen wir jetzt nicht wir
müssen die frage so wird über gehen wir
denn hier ich hab doch schon riesigen
weg gebaut
ja und dann vertrauen sie mir ich weiß
was zu tun ist warte kommentar erst mal
mit hoch wie man immer noch ein paar
fackeln damit den dbb will apple jetzt
lassen wir mal hier lang und jetzt hier
am besten zu bauen dass sie denken dass
wir da weiter hoch gelaufen sind
irgendwie so weiter hast du kriegst auch
ein bisschen ja ich hab dann setzten die
beiden anderen enden klinsmann
das habe ich erreicht nach der anderen
ok scheiße scheiße scheiße
damit haben wir die ja quasi in die irre
geführt
jetzt setzen wir hier noch cobblestone
hin
und jetzt kommen wir mit ihr um die
kurve kam ihm eine so und jetzt gehen
nämlich langsam nach oben
das war wolle er sich stark dass sogar
wolle hingesetzt habe aber einen clean
stone zu wenig hellgraue wolle
ich spiele lieber gegen einen hin kommt
erstmal aufs maul gleich eins aufs maul
mehr gibt es nicht zu sagen so jetzt
hier
wir müssen langsam an die oberfläche
kommen oder wir haben uns in den berg
rhein das war natürlich phänomenal dass
mit dem berg rheingraben finde ich echt
gerade sehr super beide helfen
ich habe keine ahnung aber wir haben auf
jeden fall und nichts liegen gelassen
wer aber auf jeden fall ich brauche
keinen kleinsten noch um den riesigen
zuzubauen sonst kann das sehen wohin
gelaufen wo wir den leuten ein tolles
ohne mein gott ist es eh keiner da unten
nur ist was mein motto das video etwas
wichtiges sagen ich muss gerade
vergessen
ok ich denke wir haben uns tatsächlich
gerade in den berg rhein weil wir sind
auf 575 und ich habe noch keinen
einzigen ehrt blog gesehen
der fall hinter dir
okay lass uns mal kurz umschauen ob
irgendwelche namen sehen nämlich sie
nichts book schon ganz senkrecht die
meisten aufträge wieder rauf gehen weil
palais glaube ich auch seine sachen
irgendwie noch verloren hat oder so ich
weiß nicht doch wenn die folge
ausgemistet das schon online sein
ich bin mir noch nicht sicher ich würde
ganz gerne jetzt tatsächlich jemals
irgendwo raus kommen
das wollte ich dann den acker so ja ich
habe apropos wo wir grad einer höhle
sind ich habe jetzt noch nicht den gamma
wert hoch gedreht weil ich mein pc neu
gemacht hat das werde ich dann
irgendwann nach dieser folge machen das
heißt abfolge fünf habt ihr dann auch in
höhlen so ein bisschen bessere
helligkeit bisher ich ja nur manuell
immer hoch gedreht
ja du bis hinter mir nannten immer am
besten die fackeln mit alle weil ich
jetzt keine mehr habe ok ich sage
mitglieder aktuell da wird nicht lange
gefackelt
du kannst ja auch noch die kohle
mitnehmen möchte
das problem ist ich habe meinen
schleichen auf alt gelegt
letztlich muss jetzt wenn ich laufe und
springe weil wenn ich wenn ich schleiche
und springe brauche ich beide hände ohne
tastatur als strich wirklich brauchen
ich weiß nicht mal was ist denn wenn wir
oberhalb sind wir müssen auf jeden fall
in dieser folge noch innen an die luft
kommen weil was ist denn wenn uns einer
nacht schauen und dann sieht entdeckt er
diesen gang und weise waren wir wenn wir
einen joint
du musst du ganz schnell bin dabei ich
bin meinen aufnahmezeit nicht wackeln
letzte hinein verliert sich egal dann
machst du jetzt einfach ausleuchtung der
rohlinge sind ja gleich mal oben sein
alter wir sind auf höhe 93 programmen
wir uns denn rein
das kann doch nicht sein in riesenbeck
der welt eine fackel
da ist noch kohle ein bisschen hurra ich
bin ein alter wo graben wir uns gerade
hell aber soll nun die fackel muss echt
meinen schleichen aufeinander taste
legen die ja wie kann das denn sein wo
graben wir uns rein
wir sind 102 und wir sind noch nicht
oben mount everest ok erde kein problem
da war jetzt aber nur ein erdwall der
scheiße klasse so ist kein alter wir
müssen richtig durchziehen das erde da
es mir gerade okay wir müssen jetzt nach
oben kommen okay es ist nacht wir sind
oben
wir sind oben ist oben
wir sind auf einem berg ganz oben okay
da wird uns wahrscheinlich keiner
vermuten leichter wind systems laufen
falls irgendjemand hier das meeting
alter das ist unfassbar dass die höhle
die wir eingegangen sind haben uns in
diesem riesigen berg eingegraben sind
wir denn behindert oh mein gott unser
loch wieder zu da kannst du dich mal wo
bist du hier den berg runter auf welcher
seite
wenn du aus dem berg rausläuft daraus
hier kommen hier lang
erst mal was das auf jeden fall ein
bisschen davon weg sind dass sie nicht
direkt an der george 3 und sind so
vieler wir haben vielleicht noch eine
halbe minute oder so oder nur eine
minute
du siehst mich aber du bist hintermänner
nun ist ein hühnchen oder 2 wir müssen
wir schon lassen ein bisschen kohle
mitnehmen und dann eventuell wir müssen
dann echt in den nächsten folge reisen
und in der höhle gut dass gleichen
strang ist fällig ich bin film ja ist
eben reisen sieht man eisen irgendwann
sieht man nicht scheiße ja gut auf jeden
fall ein bisschen weiter auf mich eben
da hinten sind schweine die können uns
auch eben holen
die ganze in der und in das macht sich
durch den lauf weg aber ich gucke nach
oben ein bisschen kontraproduktiv egal
der halle sogar das richtig viel sogar
das möchten wir noch holen
schweine sterben
okay das zuckerrohr wir haben nicht mehr
so lange auf ihr tor richtig viel
ok ich denke dass wir jetzt definitiv
safe sind außer einer scheune direkt vor
uns oder in son scheiß aber wir haben
definitiv richtig viel zuckerrohr
da müssen wir in den nächsten folgen
immer mal
ziehen haben wir hier schon was wir
schauen ob wir hier irgendwie krasseste
wir natürlich jetzt den wüsten tempel
oder sowas hier direkt das wird uns
natürlich
allerdings lief das ganze die grenze
hallo könnte wir haben immer die grenze
erreicht wir haben die folge überlebt
und wir haben die grenze erreicht komm
zu mir komm zu mir ich will mich in
einem sandloch eingraben und wie das
gleiche jeder okay wir wurden gekickt
freude ist die folge überlebt stark das
heißt die den spot ist euro wieder wenn
es euch gefallen aber wichtig oder
bewertungen freuen ich geb dir die
letzte worte felix haben vielleicht
gemerkt das ist ja wenig gesprochen habe
in der folge liegen dass ich ein
bisschen handicap war aber der luca das
sehr gut gemacht vielen dank an dich und
wir sehen uns morgen wieder was gute bis
dahin tschüss
die rub versagt jetzt macht euch vor
chr